The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
HONG LIU: So first, do you
have any questions regarding
this Hawking-Page transition
we talked about last time
because we were running
out of time, so it
was a little bit hurried.
Do you have any
questions about that?
AUDIENCE: So what's the
original thermal AdS stat?
Did you put some random
[INAUDIBLE] onto that metric,
and it will generate
some [INAUDIBLE]?
HONG LIU: Sorry?
Say it again?
AUDIENCE: So what's the
original thermal AdS state?
HONG LIU: The thermal
AdS state-- you couple
AdS to a thermal bath.
And then whatever
excitation will
be generated by that thermal
bath will be generated.
So mostly it's the graviton gas.
It's the gas of the massless
particles inside AdS.
So that essentially.
The field theory procedure
to go to cleaning space
and to make the
cleaning time periodic.
And that physically should
be interpreted as you
just a coupled decisions
to your thermal bath.
AUDIENCE: I have a question
not really related to this.
But I'm just wondering
why do we want
to consider [INAUDIBLE]
on a sphere,
because previously we
discussed about [INAUDIBLE] 4,
which is reality.
What is this?
HONG LIU: So normally when
we look at the theory,
you want to look at the
theory from as many angles as
possible.
So some of them may not be
able to directly realize it
in the experiment.
But still, it's useful from
a theoretical perspective
because that gives you
additional insights.
So we see that the
physics on the sphere
is actually quite rich.
So that actually gives you
some insight into the dynamics
and also into the
duality itself.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So there's no
condensed matter system
essentially like that.
HONG LIU: Oh, if you're
talking about condensed matter
applications, you may even
imagine in some systems,
you may be able to
put it on a sphere.
Certainly, you can put it
on a two-dimensional sphere.
And I can imagine you can put
it-- you can manipulate say,
and put some spins on the
two-dimensional sphere.
Yeah, you might be
able to do that.
Any other questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
you said there
are two kinds of
[INAUDIBLE] connected
on the same [INAUDIBLE].
HONG LIU: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So it's like two CFTs?
HONG LIU: No, it's a single CFT.
It's just a different sector
of the CFT contributes.
AUDIENCE: So it's like 0 quantum
critical point [INAUDIBLE]?
HONG LIU: No, this is a
first-order phase transition.
So it's not the
quantum critical point.
So the picture is that
you have a temperature.
So it's some TC.
So below TC, you
have a phase which
we call the thermal AdS phase.
And in this you have a
big black hole phase.
So translated from the
field theory side-- so this
goes running to the states which
energy scales into the power 0
contributes.
And here, it's dominated by the
state of energy O (N square).
Of course, in the
thermal ensemble,
every state in
principle contributes.
And in this phase, it's
dominated by the contribution
of the no energy state.
And here, it's dominated
by the high-energy state.
And really the high-energy state
also has a much higher entropy.
And then they dominate
your thermal ensemble.
Does this answer your question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, this looks
like in any transition,
you have [INAUDIBLE] carry
energy and also [INAUDIBLE].
HONG LIU: Yeah, it is a
little bit similar to that.
There's also an
entropy thing there.
Yeah, it's a balance
between two things.
But the details
is very different.
The details are different.
There's some
qualitative similarity.
AUDIENCE: So I read on
the paper [INAUDIBLE].
He said that the Hawking-Page
transition on the field theory
side is due to some
kind of deconfinement
and confinement of QCD.
HONG LIU: Yeah, so that's a
heuristic way to say about it.
So the key thing is that here,
it's not really a confinement
or not confined because
in the [INAUDIBLE] series,
there's no confinement.
It's just scaled in
[? Warren's ?] theory.
And so in the sense he says
this is confined-- so he
called this a confined phase.
And this is a deconfined phase--
it's based on the following.
It just refers to
these two behaviors.
So in QCD, which will generating
confinement or deconfinement--
so in QCD, we have
[INAUDIBLE] 3.
But if you scale
into infinity, then
you will find in QCD
in the confined phase,
the free energy will
scale as N with N power 0.
But in the deconfined
phase, which
is scale-- obviously
the N square.
So that aspect of
scaling is the same
as a serious risk confinement.
So that aspect is similar.
So he essentially
refers to this aspect.
But on the sphere, every
state has to be a singlet.
So in some sense,
this notion there
is no genuinely
notion of confinement
as we say in the QCD
in the flat space case.
If you read his
paper, he actually
described this very clearly.
Yeah, he just called this
a deconfinement transition
the heuristic way.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about the sum by which we
calculate partition function.
The previous class on
Monday, you wrote it as sum
over energies.
The degeneracy of that
[INAUDIBLE] factor.
And you noticed
that both of these
grew at exponential to
something times N squared.
One was positive,
and one was negative.
I was wondering if it's
possible that sum diverges?
HONG LIU: No, that
sum does not diverge.
That sum is always
proportional to n square.
Yeah, depending on what
you mean the sum diverges.
So that's just from the
definition of your partition
function.
So it's just the sum
of all possible states.
And then you can just
reach this-- yeah, when
you have a large
number of states,
you can just roughly write it as
a continuous integral and then
with the density of states.
And so the key is
that what happens
to the density of states--
so you're asking maybe
whether this
integral will diverge
when it equals infinity.
So when it equals
infinity, you will
see that say supposing
E scale as N cubed.
Then you will see that
the density of state
actually does not
grow that fast.
And actually, it's only
for the E of O(N squared),
then they scale in the same way.
They scale in the same way.
So that's why you
have this balance.
And if you are not in the
scaling with [INAUDIBLE].
If you have N cubed, and
then this will dominate.
So that factor
will be suppressed.
Any other questions?
OK, very good.
So now let's go to entanglement.
So first, let me say a few
words about entanglement entropy
itself.
So this is very
elementary stuff,
even though maybe
not everybody knows.
So let's consider a quantum
system, just a general quantum
system.
So let's separate the
degrees of freedom
into two parts, say A
plus B. So AB together
is the whole system.
We just separated the
degrees of freedom.
So essentially by
definition, the Hilbert
space of the system-- then
we'll have a tensor structure.
So the full Hilbert space
will be a tensor product
over the Hilbert
space for the A part
and tensored with the
Hilbert space in the B part.
OK?
And consider, of
course, in general, we
have an infinite
dimensional system.
But in the case if you have
say a [INAUDIBLE] Hilbert
space-- so i f this M
dimension, this is N dimension,
then the total Hilbert space
will be M times N dimension.
And the typical wave function
will have the form-- will be
some sum-- say you can write
it in some basis in A and times
some wave function
writing some bases in B.
And this actually means that
the Hilbert space is a tensor
product.
It's just your wave form can
typically have this form.
So we say that AB-- so we say
that in the states psi that AB
are entangled if psi cannot be
written as a single product--
rather than the sum of product
and if you just have a single
product.
So for a simple state,
it might be easy to see.
But if I write the very
complicated state which
many-- in principle,
write the state
in some bases which look
at the complicated sum.
But they may be some other
bases and be a simple product.
So in general, it's
actually hard to tell.
In general, it's hard to tell,
even though it's easy to say.
But in general,
it's hard to say.
So the entangled
entropy-- so let me just
call it EE just to save space.
EE essentially
provides a measure
to quantify the entanglement
between A and B--
because even in the case
which you know this state is
in entangled state,
you may still
want to ask how much
they are entangled.
Entanglement entropy provides
the way to quantify it.
So the definitions
are very simple.
So first we look at
this the density matrix
for the total system.
So if the system is
in the state psi,
then the density matrix
for the total system
would be just on the psi
conjugate-- psi itself.
So in this basic matrix,
we just trace out
all the degrees of freedom in
B. So since the Hilbert space
have a tensor product structure,
you can always do this.
Then what you get is you
get this the density matrix.
And then here, you
get a density matrix
which only depends on the
degree of freedom in A.
And then we just calculate
the Von Neumann entropy
corresponding to this row
A. So entangled entropy
is just defined to be
[INAUDIBLE] entropy associates
resistance in the matrix
rho A. So this rho A
is often called the
reduced density matrix.
And the Von Neumann entropy
associated with the reduced
density matrix is defined
as the entanglement entropy.
OK?
So this provides a
very good the measure
because say if SA is equal to
0, from our knowledge of the Von
Neumann entropy,
you can immediately
deduce where the SA is equal
to 0 if only if the rhos A,
this density matrix
is a pure state.
It's a pure state.
And then from here, you can also
deduce rho A is a pure state.
This reduced density matrix
comes from this procedure
as a pure state.
Only if the psi can be
written as a simple product.
So this tells you as
when SA is non-zero,
then you can be sure this
state must be non-entangled.
So whenever SA is
equal to 0, you
can be sure this
is non-entangled.
When SA is not
equal to 0, you know
for sure A and B must be
entangled in this state.
So that's why this
is a good measure.
OK?
And then the value of
SA then will tell you
how entangled the system is.
And also, you may
immediately ask
the question what happens
instead of defining the rho A?
Of course, you can
also do the same thing.
You trace out A to define
out rho B and then the
define the entropy
for the rho B. OK?
Define entropy for the
rho B. But you can easily
show for any pure state
psi SA always equals to SB.
So it doesn't matter
which are symmetric.
So it doesn't matter which
one you're looking at.
So this is very easy
to prove, essentially
just following from something
called a Schmidt decomposition.
And essentially right to this
state in terms of Schmidt
decomposition between the
degrees of freedom rho A and B.
And then you can show that
rho A and rho B essentially
have the same eigenvalues.
And if rho A and rho B have the
same eigenvalues, of course,
then the entropy will be the
same, because the entropy only
depends on the eigenvalues.
OK?
Any questions about this?
Good.
So here is what a mixed
state-- about a pure state,
let me just say a side remark.
So if AB, the total system is
in a mixed state-- so far always
is in the pure state.
But suppose it's
in the mixed state.
Suppose the system itself is
described by a density matrix.
So the total system
itself is spread.
In general, SA is
not equal to SB.
OK?
Not only in general,
it's not equal to-- SA
is not equal to SB.
And in such a case, the
entanglement entropy
also contains classical
statistical correlations
of the mixed state--
so in addition to
quantum correlations.
It's almost trivial to see
because the people suppose
here is not a pure state.
So here you replace it
by the density matrix.
And when you trace all the B
in this density matrix, then,
of course, there's still
some original uncertainty
in the previous density
matrix remaining in A.
And then they will come into
this entropy-- so as defined,
will depend on the
classical uncertainties--
classical statistical
uncertainties
of your original density matrix.
So for a mixed state-- so
that's why for a mixed state,
the internal entropy is not a
very good measure of quantum
entanglements, because
it's contaminated
by classical
statistical information.
But for today, we
all need to talk
about the pure-- mostly
talk about the pure.
Yeah, we actually
talk about in general.
But I want you to
keep this in mind.
So any questions so far?
So just to give you an a
little bit more intuition,
let's look at this
very simple example
to calculate entangled entropy.
So let's consider
a two-spin system.
So let's consider you
have two spins, OK?
So this is my A and B. So this
has a two-dimensional Hilbert
space.
This has a two-dimensional
Hilbert space.
Altogether, you have a
four-dimensional Hilbert space.
So for example, so let
me consider such a state.
So this looks like
a complicated state.
But actually, this can be
written as a single product,
because you it can
be written at OK,
I hope this notation is for me.
It's OK with you.
You just A and B--
A spin and B spin.
So even though in this
space, this is written as
say a sum of state.
It looks the entangleds.
But in fact, it's not
because you can write it
in terms of a simple product.
So this is another
entangled state.
Of course, for the simple
system, it's very easy to tell.
But to give you a
complicated system
with many, many,
degrees of freedom,
then it becomes very hard.
And then entangled
entropy becomes useful.
So now let me give you an
example to calculated entangled
entropy.
So let's consider
a state like this.
So let's see some parameter.
So clearly this state is
entangled because you cannot
write it as a simple product.
So now, let's check it.
Now, let's check it.
So you can look at the full
density matrix of the system.
You just look at this--
the bra and the ket itself.
And then just do the product.
And you get the quotient theta--
under the [INAUDIBLE] terms.
So you just take the
product with itself.
And then let's try
to find what's rho A.
So you trace out
degrees of freedom of B.
So this is our B,
the second spin.
And now let's trace out
degrees of freedom B--
trace out the second spin--
so rho A. Goes one into we
trace out the B in here.
So when you trace
out the B, you just
take the end product
between these two.
So these are the same.
So this will remain.
And so you have this.
And similarly, this
one you have that.
These two are the same.
So when you take the
trace, this is nonzero.
But this too will give
you 0, because this one is
orthogonal to this one.
And this spin is
orthogonal to that spin.
So that's what you get.
And then now you can usually
just write down the entropy.
So this is the entangled
entropy for these two states--
for this two spin system
as a general function
of this parameter theta.
So now let's plot these
as a function of S theta.
So clearly, this is
a period function.
We only need to go to pi over 2.
And then you have
something like this.
And you can easily
plot that function.
You will see
something like this.
So when theta is equal to 0.
This is equal to 0
because this term is 0.
This term is also 0 because
of the quotient theta
square is equal to 1.
When theta equals to
pi over 2, this term
becomes 0 and this
term also becomes,
because it's [INAUDIBLE] 0.
But this maximum in the
pi over 2 or pi over 4.
So I had a pi over 4.
Of course, you can also go
to the pi equals to minus 4.
OK, you can go do plus minus 4.
I didn't go to the [INAUDIBLE].
Yeah, anyway, so these are
called the maximum entangled
states.
This is a maximum entangled.
So this is a state in which
you have the highest entropy.
Any questions so far?
AUDIENCE: You switched it.
It should be up down.
It's down.
HONG LIU: Right, that's right.
OK, good.
So let me also say a few
things about the properties
of the entanglement entropy.
So there are many properties
you can derive from here.
Let me only say a
few important ones.
OK, so one property of
the entangled entropy
is called subadditivity
condition.
So if you can see that
the two systems A and B,
then you can show that
S(AB), the entropy
for the total system,
is smaller than the sum
of the separate system.
So when I write AB, I
mean the combined system.
OK?
And this is greater than
the difference between them.
So this is so-called the
subadditive condition.
And then intuitively,
you can understand.
So if you have entropy
of A and entropy of B,
you add them together, then it's
larger than the entropy of AB
because there is
some redundancy.
There might be some
redundancy here.
Yeah, because when
you add AB together,
there may be some common
correlation between them.
And so this is
greater than that.
OK, intuitively that's
what this inequality means.
And also there are some property
for the strong subadditivity
condition.
AUDIENCE: I don't
quite understand--
HONG LIU: Yes?
AUDIENCE: What S of
A and S of B means?
HONG LIU: So this is
the entropy for the A.
This is the entropy for the B.
AUDIENCE: Don't we
need this to partition
system A into two subsystems?
HONG LIU: No, you don't--
let me explain my notation.
So S(A) means the
entropy equals 1
if you integrate out
everything else except A.
And S(B) means you
integrate everything
else except B.
And S(AB) be means
to integrate everything
else except A and B.
And this is S(AB).
AUDIENCE: But in our case, A
and B is all that there is.
HONG LIU: No, no, no.
Now I'm just doing generally.
Once I have this definition,
so this can be-- even
AB is a total-- yeah, so this
can apply both to the case
I said earlier-- say
if you divide-- here I
just-- so this AB does not
have to be the same as that AB.
Here I'm just talking
about only two subsystems.
AUDIENCE: So it's
for example, S(A)
is like-- A and the supplement
as two parts of the system.
And they could have
some entanglement.
S(A) is just an
entanglement field.
HONG LIU: A, S(A)
is the entanglement
of A with the rest.
And S(B) is the entanglement
of B between B and the rest.
And the S(AB) is
entangled between the AB
together with the rest.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So to clarify one
thing, when you say S of A,
we have this whole system.
It means that trace
everything which is not A?
HONG LIU: Yeah, that's right.
Any more questions about this?
So here when I write
to those expressions,
I assume A and B don't
have interceptions, OK?
have interceptions.
You can also have the strong
subbadditivity condition.
So this is pretty easy to prove.
If we have time, it takes
five minutes to prove.
But the strong subadditivity
which I'm going to write down.
So strong additivity is
involving three systems.
Now, you have to add
the three systems.
And then greater than ABC-- OK?
So, again, intuitively, the
meaning of that inequality
is clear.
So the first
inequality just says
that I have two systems here.
And the sum of
these two systems--
the entropy of
is greater than the sum
between the combined
system and the intersection
between the two systems,
OK, because C in the
section between the two.
And ABC is the whole
thing combined.
And similarly here, he said
they have S(A) and S(B).
I have two A and B. So
I trace out the system.
Outside A, I get entropy for A.
I trace the system outside B,
anyway for B. This
inequality says if now you
attach A C to A and C to B, a
common system to both A and B.
And then the resulting system
will be larger than the B form.
So if you add something,
we increase the entropy.
That, of course, is
intuitively clear,
because if you have entropy
essentially parameterized
the unknown part of the system.
And if you add the third
system, and then this
just increase your unknown and
then increase your entropy.
So this strong
subadditivity condition
is actually very hard to prove.
It's very hard to prove.
It can get rather mathematical
and requires some effort
to do it.
But this one is
pretty easy to do.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Can [INAUDIBLE] about
the first of the two equations?
For strong subadditivity,
what's the first equation?
HONG LIU: Yeah,
so this means-- so
look at this as a single system.
This is a single system.
That means that the sum of these
two-- the entropy of this two
system is greater than
the sum of the combined
system under the intersection.
Any questions about this?
Good.
So this concludes the
very simple introduction
to the entangled entropy.
AUDIENCE: Does
the first one have
any implications of topology?
HONG LIU: Sorry, what
do you mean by topology?
AUDIENCE: Because it's like the
intersection of the combined
thing.
HONG LIU: Yeah, so
as classical entropy,
this is a very simple thing.
You can easily convince
yourself if ABC
are classical systems, and
just classical distributions,
describe classical
probabilities,
statistical distributions.
And then with those things, you
can understand this inequality
just by drawing this kind of
standard diagram corresponding
to the different sets.
The quantum mechanics proving
those things are actually
not trivial are not trivial.
Quantum mechanically,
they no longer come in
a very intuitive way.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I was noticing
something curious
about the last line classically.
If A and B are the same, I think
the equation will still hold.
But quantumly--
HONG LIU: It still holds.
AUDIENCE: Doesn't it
not hold quantumly?
HONG LIU: No, they are supposed
to hold quantum mechanically.
AUDIENCE: But we are under the
assumption that A, B, and C--
they don't overlap, right?
I'm saying if A and B
are totally overlapping.
HONG LIU: No, but
this inequality
I'm writing in a way which
they are not intersecting.
You can write them in a
way which they intersect.
And I'm just
writing in this way.
So the condition for
this particular form ABC
is not supposed to intersect.
AUDIENCE: Right, I'm saying
if we set A equals to B.
HONG LIU: No, no, then you
cannot use this equation.
Then you have to
write the equation
in somewhat different way, which
apply to the intersection case.
You can do them just choosing
to write in the way which
did only intersect.
AUDIENCE: OK, but the
thing I want to say
is that we can still keep the
bottom equation classically,
even if we took--
HONG LIU: No, both are
applied classically.
Both are trivial classically.
You can understand very
easily classically.
It's just quantum mechanically,
it's no longer trivial.
Quantum mechanics is
no longer trivial.
And there are various ways
you can write those equations.
I'm just choosing to write the
way which ABC don't intersect.
And you can also write
the way, just rename them
so that they intersect.
AUDIENCE: So [INAUDIBLE].
So this is true for any
entanglement state we choose?
HONG LIU: Any state,
yeah, density matrix.
Whether it's a pure
state or density matrix,
it doesn't matter--
a general statement.
OK, good.
So this concludes the
short introduction
to the entangled entropy itself.
And you may know that the
entanglement entropy actually
plays a very important role.
Entanglement and
entanglement entropy
itself plays a very important
role in quantum information
and quantum computing because
of quantum entanglement
is the kind of
quantum correlations
which you don't
have classically.
So this EPR paradox and
the [INAUDIBLE] inequality,
and the teleportation--
all those things
that take advantage of.
But that's not our
main point here.
So what I'm going
to talk about next
is actually entangled
entropy is also
starting playing a
very important role
in our understanding of
many-body physics and the space
time.
So now, let's talk about
the entanglement entropy
in many-body systems in
quantum many-body systems.
So I hope you're familiar with
this word many-body systems.
It's just a system of a
large number of particles
or a large number
of constituents.
So quantum field theory issue
is a many-bodied system.
Any quantum field theory
is a many-body system.
But this also includes
many other lattice systems,
which condensed
matter people use,
which are not necessary
quantum fields-- can be written
as a quantum field theory.
OK?
So now let's again consider
just a simplified case.
Let's consider a system which
is composed of A and B--
so A plus B. And then I will
say some trivial statements.
So if H is HA plus HB.
So now we talk
about Hamiltonian.
So far, I'm not using
actually many-body systems.
What I'm talking about are
pretty generic systems.
So even the
Hamiltonian is actually
just a direct sum
of the Hamiltonian
for A and Hamiltonian for B.
If they don't couple, then of
course, the [INAUDIBLE] state
or, in particular, the
ground state is unentangled.
So you just find the ground
state of each system.
And then that's the ground
state of the total system.
And also, in general, if you
start with the initial stage,
which is unentangled, with
the initial state, which
is unentangled, it will
remain unentangled.
So if you started with
an unentangled state,
you wove it using this
Hamiltonian, of course,
it will just act on
the specific part.
And then you will
remain unentangled.
OK?
And now let's consider we
have H equals to HA plus HB.
But now they also
have interactions
between the A and the B.
So A and B are coupled.
Then in general, we can just
repeat what he said here.
Then the ground state
is now entangled.
OK, and now if you start
with the initial state,
even if you start with the
initial unentangled state,
it becomes entangled on
Hamiltonian evolution.
So in general, we
will expect-- so just
based on this
general expectation--
so you would expect
the ground state
of a typical many-body
system will be actually
rather entangled.
It will be rather entangled
unless the Hamiltonian factor
rides into all three particles.
The factor rides into
the Hilbert space
at each point-- for
each degree of freedom.
But now let's talk about
the many-body systems
we're interested in.
So they're either typical
condensed matter systems
or quantum field series.
So in typical condensed matter
systems, we face this problem.
So in typical generic condensed
matter systems of quantum field
theory, in general,
no matter how
you divide A and B-- so
generic H AB is non-zero.
But not only is
H AB is non-zero,
it's in general, H AB-- so the
whole Hamiltonian, including
H AB is local.
This is a very
important concept.
It's local.
But local will
mean the following.
For example, let me
give you an example.
For example, one of the very
important condensed matter
systems is, of course,
the Heisenberg model.
So essentially, you
have the Hamiltonian.
So you can see the lattice
in whatever dimension
you're interested in whatever
kind of lattice you are.
At each lattice,
there is a spin.
So consider you have
a lattice of spins.
And then you'll have nearest
neighbor interactions
between the
neighboring spins, so
some of the nearest neighbors.
So you can imagine you
have a lattice system.
And each point on the
lattice, you have a spin.
And each spin interacts
only with the spins nearby.
So this is a local interaction.
So by local interaction, means
that the only direct couple
to the spin falls
distance away from it.
So this is an example
of a local system.
And all our QFTs
are local systems.
All our QFTs are local systems.
For example, let me just
write down the phi 4
theory, for example,
phi 4 theory.
Then phi at each
point-- so now you
have to go back to your first
day of your quantum field
theory where you
emphasize locality.
So the phi evaluated
at each point now
is independent of
degrees of freedom.
Under the quantum
field theory, it's
a Hilbert space of
a tensor product
of the degrees of freedom.
OK?
Under the form of the Lagrangian
say if you discretize it--
and this is only
involving coupling
between the neighboring
point, because the derivative
is only dependent on
the second derivative.
And this only depends
on the value of phi
at the single point.
So the typical
quantum field theory
as far as you have found
a number of derivatives,
it's all local.
It's all OK intact.
It's all local.
OK?
So in other words, in
these kind of systems,
let me go back here.
So this is very important.
In other words, in
these kind of systems,
so let me just
imagine-- so let me just
say this box is the whole thing.
It's the whole whatever
space I live in.
And I divide it into A B.
So this tells you that for
typical condensed matter
or quantum field series,
the H AB is only supported.
So let me call this epsilon.
So that tells that H
AB is only supported
near the boundary
between A and B,
because there is only
local interactions.
So the part of the Hamiltonian
which directly covers A and B
is only within this part.
And this epsilon is added
on the lattice spacing
is order of lattice spacing,
which in the case of a lattice
system or in a
quantum field theory,
it would be your
short distance cutoff.
So if you try to discretize
your field theory,
then this will be a
short distance cutoff.
So similarly, I can
consider another shape of A.
So suppose I can
see the circular A.
And then, again,
the part of which
H AB is only supported in
the region between these two
dashed lines.
And those dashed
would be considered
to be very close to the
A. I'm just going to pick.
But this should be the
short distance cutoff.
OK?
And again, the H AB is
only supported in here.
So this is an important
feature of which
you have a local Hamiltonian.
Let me just write one more word.
So H AB only involves
degrees of freedom
here-- the boundary of A. So
this means the boundary of A.
So this turns out to have very,
very important implications--
the fact that the
Hamiltonian is local.
And that they only direct
and mediate coupling
between the degrees of freedom
near the boundary of A.
And they have very
important consequences.
So now I'm just
telling you the result
which is a result of
having accumulated
for many, many years
since the early '90s.
So then when I
find in the ground
state of a local
Hamiltonian in general
you may construct some kind
of evil counterexamples.
But in general, in
the ground state
of a local Hamiltonian--
in the ground
state of a local
Hamiltonian-- any
just choose any region
A-- you integrate out
the degrees of
freedom outside of it.
So let me emphasize
an important point.
Let me just pause to
emphasize an important, which
is only increasing
what I'm saying here.
In this definition of the
entangled matrix which I just
erased, you just need
to have a partition
of a degree of freedom
between A and B.
The way you partition
it does not matter.
How you partition
You can partition it in
whatever way you want.
But for typical this
kind of lattice system
or for quantum field theory,
there's a very large partition.
And the partition is just
based on the locality.
It's just based on the degrees
of freedom at each point.
You just factorize
your Hilbert space
in terms of degrees of
freedom at each point.
So of course in the lattice
system, it's obvious.
You have a spin at each lattice.
And for the quantum
field theory,
you just factorize your
degrees of freedom.
At each point, you
factorize them.
And so this locality
provides a natural partition
of your degrees of freedom.
And when we talk
about A and the B,
we always talk about in
terms of the space location.
And it's natural to talk
about the partition in terms
of just your metric locations.
So is this point clear?
I just want to
emphasize this point.
So then you find that in
general for the ground
state of a local Hamiltonian
satisfy so-called area
law is that the leading term
of the entanglement entropy
is given by the area
of the boundary of A--
this applies no
matter which dimension
you are in generic
dimensions-- and divide it
by a short distance cutoff
of the lattice spacing.
It's some number.
So A is a dimensionless number.
So area-- we can see the
d-dimensional theory--
so d-dimensional system.
Then the spatial dimension
will be d minus 1.
And then you go to the
boundary of some region.
The boundary of region A.
Then that will be a d minus 2
dimensional surface.
And then this would be
the area of that surface.
So this may cover a
dimensionless number.
And then you can have
some pre-factor here
which depend on your systems.
So this formula tells you
a very important physics.
This tells you that
generically if you--
in such kind of systems,
AB are entangled.
But the entanglement between
AB between A is complementary,
which I just call A
and B, are dominated
by short-range entanglements
near the boundary of A
where this H AB is supported.
OK?
So this is also very intuitive
once you load the answer--
once you load the
answer, because we
emphasized that H AB only
coupled to degrees of freedom
nearby.
And then we look
at the ground state
you find most of the
degrees of freedom in here
don't entangle with B. Only
the degrees of freedom them
near the boundary of A are
entangled with B because
of this interaction.
This local interaction
directly leads
to the entanglement between
the degrees of freedom nearby.
And those degrees of freedom,
if they are far away,
they might be entangled.
But they are not dominant.
OK?
So I have put many dots here.
So included in those dots
are possible long-range
entanglements.
Because when you find
the ground state,
you really have to extremize
the energy of the total system.
You don't only look
at the small part.
So there's always some kind
of long-range entanglement
beyond this H AB.
But this formula tells you
that this short distance
entanglement dominates.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: One question-- in QFT
in general, like [INAUDIBLE],
there's really all
the interactions
are perfectly local, I believe.
But in string theory, are there
any non-local interactions
that occur.
Are there any interactions
with non-local?
HONG LIU: Yeah, it will
depend on the scale.
In string theory when
we say non-local,
it's non-local at the
alpha prime scale.
And that alpha prime can
perfectly be our short distance
cutoff here.
When I talk about
local and non-local,
I'm talking about
infinite versus finite.
For example, here,
when I talk about
whether this is
a local system, I
don't have to have
a nearest neighbor.
As far as this matches
this point only directly
coupled to the finite
distance neighbor.
And this can see the
local Hamiltonian.
But from the quantum field
theory point of view,
this might be
considered non-local.
You see what I mean?
Depending on your scale.
AUDIENCE: So is
there anything that
appears in string theory which
is non-local at any scale?
Or is the non-locality
just some--
HONG LIU: Yeah, so
the string theory
itself does not give
you that non-locality,
but the black hole may.
AUDIENCE: Oh, interesting.
HONG LIU: The black
hole seems to give you
some kind of non-locality which
we don't fully understand.
So that's why the black
hole is so puzzling.
And the [INAUDIBLE] of
string theory, you're
non-local in the
scale of alpha prime.
Yeah, if it's alpha
prime sufficient small,
it's like a local theory.
And even if alpha prime is
big, if you look at very much,
it is still like local.
AUDIENCE: I see.
HONG LIU: Yeah, but black
hole can make things
very long distance.
So that's the tricky
thing about black holes.
OK, so this is
something which are
is interesting and was first
discovered in the early '90s.
But in hindsight,
it's very intuitive.
In hindsight, it's
very intuitive.
So even though this formula,
even though this term
is universal, but this
coefficient is actually
highly non-universal.
Normally, by saying
universal, we
mean something which is
common to different systems.
So this coefficient actually
depends on the details
of individual systems.
Say if you calculate for
the Heisenberg model,
or if you calculate for the
free scale of field theory,
or free fermion theory, and
then this coefficient in general
is different, are depending
on how you define your cutoff.
So even though this
formula is universal,
but those pre-factors actually
are highly non-universal.
But the partial
excitement-- there
are many things people
are excited about in terms
of entropy.
This is one thing,
this area law,
because the area law is nice.
Then this can be used as
a distinguishing property
of a ground state.
If you go to a
highly excited state,
then you find the generic
distribution inside
and A and B will be entangled.
And [INAUDIBLE] highly excited.
But only in the ground state,
somehow only near the boundary
they are entangled.
This is also makes sense,
because if it were high energy
then you can excite it,
because from the very far away
from H AB, then of course,
everything would be entangled.
AUDIENCE: So just
one other question.
So why are you
dividing by epsilon?
HONG LIU: No, this
estimation is a number.
Making the dimension
is numbered.
This is only a short-distance
information here.
So that is spatial
short-distance cut off.
AUDIENCE: Right,
the only reason I
ask is that intuitively it
seems that the entropy should
be proportional to this thin
volume around the boundary.
But that doesn't--
OK, I don't know.
HONG LIU: Yeah, you have to make
it into a dimensionless number.
You have to be
proportional to the area.
So there's a very simple way
to understand that thing.
So the area divided by lattice
spacing-- so what is this guy?
This is wonderfully
a lattice volume.
That is the lattice
area on the surface.
So essentially this tells you
how many degrees of freedom
are lying on that boundary.
AUDIENCE: OK, interesting.
HONG LIU: Yeah, OK?
So is this clear?
OK, I think I'm spending
too much time on this.
Anyway, so excited
in the last decade--
the main excitement
about entangled
entropy in the last decade.
The one thing is
about this behavior,
then you can use it as a
characterization of the ground
state.
But a lot of the
excitement about this thing
is on those dot, dot, dots.
So people actually find
that the subleading term--
some excitement.
Yeah, I'm just saying--
from last decade people
have discover that the
subleading terms in entangled
entropy other than
this area term which
come in from long-range
entanglements.
So this captures the
short-range entanglement
from the long-range
entanglement can actually
provide important
characterizations of a system.
So let me just
mention two examples.
So it will be little
bit fast because we
are a little bit-- do you
want a break for the last day?
AUDIENCE: Well, when
you say it like that--
HONG LIU: OK, good.
OK, thanks.
So let me just quickly
talk about two examples
because I want to talk
about the holographic case.
So the first thing is something
called the topological can
be used to characterize
so-called topological order
in 2 plus 1 dimensions.
So since the '90s, mid
'80s, and the '980s,
people discovered
that if you look
at the typical gapped
system-- so when
we say a gapped system means
that system between the ground
state and the first excited
state have a finite energy gap.
So our general understanding
of a gap system is that
in the ground state because
you have a finite gap,
and there's sufficient
low energies,
you simply cannot
excite anything.
You have low energy because you
have a finite gap to the first
excited state.
You cannot excite anything.
So essentially, when you look
at the correlation functions,
we can look at
all the variables.
They all only have
short-range correlations.
The cannot have
long-range correlation,
because there's nothing to
propagate you to long distance.
And because long
distance requires
massive degrees of freedom.
And because you have a gap, you
don't have such massive degrees
of freedom.
So the typical conventional
idea about the gap system
is that all correlations
should be short-ranged.
And so this is a
condition that meets them.
But in the late
'80s and early '90s,
our colleague, Xiao-Gang
Wen, he introduced
this notion of a
topological ordered system
based on fractional
quantum Hall effect.
So he actually reasoned that
there can be gap systems even
though I have a finite gap,
but in the ground state
actually contain
long-range correlations--
nontrivial, long-range
correlations.
And those long-range
correlations cannot be seen
using the standard observables.
So if you are using the
standard observables-- say
correlation functions of local
operators, you don't see them.
You only see the
short-range correlations.
And those long-range
correlations
are topological in nature.
You have to see it
in some subtle ways.
And then in the '80s, except
in the late '80s, early '90s,
he was trying to argue
in some [INAUDIBLE] way
to argue there is such kind
of subtle correlations.
But then around 2000,
maybe 2005, then
he realized actually you can
see it very easily directly
from the ground
state wave function.
You just calculate
the entangled entropy.
entangled entropy.
So in entangled entropy,
you always have this--
so this is a 2 plus 1
system, and then the boundary
is just a line.
So essentially, you
just have a boundary.
It's a number-- the
length of the boundary
divided by your
cutoff, but then it
turns out for these kind of
topological ordered system,
there is a finite constant
as a subleading term.
And this finite constant is
independent of the shape of A
and independent of length
of A and independent
of whatever A is purely
topological in nature.
And so if you have
achieved a gap system then
this gamma will be 0.
So you look at a free
massive scale of field--
then this gamma will be 0.
But for those topological
ordered systems,
this gamma would be non-zero.
And it tells you actually there
is long-range correlations
which are encoded in the
entanglement entropy,
because this cannot come from
the local thing because this
does not depend on the shape of
A, does not depend on N sub A,
does not depend
on anything of A.
So this is really
topological in nature.
It tells you this can only
be some long-range, subtle
correlation, which
is only capture
by these entangled
entropy rather
than by the standard
correlation functions.
OK
So this is one discovery which
is generated a lot of interest
in the entangled entropy
because now this can
be used to define the phases.
OK, you can actually
define non-trivial phases
using this number.
And so this is the first thing.
So this is about in
condensed matter systems.
In quantum field theories ,
this can be used to characterize
the number of degrees
of freedom of a QFT.
Again, this is a long story.
But I don't have time.
So let me just tell
you a short story.
So first let me look at 1
plus 1 dimensions, a CFT.
So for 1 plus 1 dimension
of CFT or important
the quantity is so-called
essential charge.
So have you all heard of
essential charge or not really?
It just says, imagine you have
a 1 plus 1 dimensional CFT.
And for each CFT, you can
define a single number, which
is called the center charge.
And this center charge
is very important
because it controls
the asymptotic density
of state of the system.
So if you look at the system
go to very high energies,
and the density of
state essentially
is controlled by this number C.
So essentially C can
be used to characterize
a number of degrees of freedom.
And the C will appear
in many other places.
But I don't have
time to explain.
But anyway, there's something
called the central charge,
which can be used to
characterize numbers of degrees
of freedom of the system.
And thus, if you look at the
entanglement entropy for 1
plus 1 dimensional system for
1 plus 1 dimension of CFT.
So in 1 plus 1
dimension, you only
have a line in the
spatial direction.
So then this takes A just to
be a sacrament of length l.
Then you find when
you integrate out
everything else, the
entangled entropy
for the A given by C divided
by 3 log L divided by epsilon.
Again, epsilon is a
short distance cutoff.
And the C is your center charge.
So you see that the
entanglement entropy-- first you
notice that formula
becomes degenerate when
you go to the two dimensions.
It's equal to 1
plus 1 dimensions.
1 plus 1 dimension the were
played by something like this.
You have log epsilon.
So the key important
thing is not the prefactor
because of the log.
The prefactor is
actually reversal.
And it's actually controlled
by the central charge.
So that saves you from
entangled entropy.
You can actually read
the central charge
and actually read what
are the numbers of degrees
of was freedom of the system.
So the fact that the central
charge in the 1 plus 1
dimensional CFT captures the
number of degrees of freedom
was known-- known
before people thought
about entangled entropy.
But it turned out-- and
people spent many years
trying too hard to generalize
this concept to higher
dimensional series.
And it turned out they are
very hard to generalize.
People didn't really
know how to do it.
But now we know
because you can just
generalize the entangled
entropy to higher dimensions.
And then you find the same
kind of central charge
which appeared.
You find again
things can be defined
as analog of the single
charge in 1 plus 1 dimension
appears in the entangled entropy
in the higher dimensions.
And then they can be
used to characterize
the number degrees of freedom.
And so in some sense, the
entangled entropy really
provides a unified way to
think about this central charge
and to characterize the
number of degrees of freedom
across all dimensions--
across all dimensions.
And so this is a key formula.
Actually, I first realized by
our old friend Frank Wilczek
when they studied
free field theory.
And people later generalized
to show this actually
works for any CFT.
Good.
So now finally, we can talk
about holographic entangled
entropy with lots
of preparations.
So this just gives
you some taste
of actually why we are actually
interested in entangled entropy
and why this actually not only
people in quantum computing
or quantum information
people are interested in it.
People are doing
condensed matter-- people
doing quantum field theory
are also interested in it.
And now people who are
doing string theory
are also interested
in it because
of this holographic
entanglement entropy.
So suppose we have our CFT.
So a two-dimensional
CFT with a gravity
dual-- so a dual to some
theory in d plus 1 dimensional
[INAUDIBLE] space time.
So let me give you origin A. How
do I find the entangled-- what
is the counterpart
of this entangled
entropy on the gravity side?
So this is the question.
So let me just draw this figure.
Suppose this is
the box again that
represents your total system.
And then this carves
out of region A.
Then the question what
does this translate into?
And the graph decides.
OK, so now in the
boundary, we have
some region A is equal to 0.
So for this question, in
some sense it's difficult
because it's not
like other questions
we've talked about before.
So we also know
partition function.
You can say the partition
function cannot be the same.
Those things appear
to be natural.
Here, there is no natural
thing you can think about,
because you cannot
define entangled entropy
as a partition function.
Entangled entropy have to
involve in so-called trace
out the degrees of freedom.
Then take the logarithm.
It's highly non-local and
a complicated procedure.
And it's obvious how you would
define on the gravity side--
how you would guess
on the gravity side.
So it's quite remarkable
and the Ryu-Takayanagi,
they just made the guess.
And then worked.
So the proposal is just find
the minimal area surface,
let me call gamma A,
which extends in the back
and with the boundary
of A as the boundary.
You first find the surface.
And then you say the
entangled entropy for A
is just the area of this
gamma A divided by 40 Newton.
And this is the Ryu-Takayanagi.
So the idea is that you find
a surface of a minimal area
is going into the back, but
ending on the boundary of A.
So this is your gamma A. And
you find such a minimal surface.
Then you divide by 40 Newton.
OK?
So let me just
mention one thing.
Let me just note a simple
scene, because again,
the A of the boundary, this
is d minus 2 dimensional.
And A and the gamma A are
all d minus 1 dimensional.
So this is d minus
2 dimension is
what we said before
because A is just
a region in your
spatial section.
So A is a d minus 1 dimensional.
And the boundary A will
d minus 2 dimensional.
And the gamma A
would be a surface
which is ending on the boundary
of A. This ends on that thing.
So this is also the d
minus 1 dimensional.
And this is d minus
1 dimensional.
So this area have
dimension d minus 1.
And that's precisely
the dimension
of G Newton in the d plus
1 dimensional [INAUDIBLE]
of space time.
And then this is a
dimensionless number.
OK, because we did it
the SA with dimensions.
So you can say this is
a very difficult guess.
You can also say this is a very
simple guess, because clearly
this formula is motivated by
the black hole entropy formula.
You may say, ah,
black hole entropy
is something divided 4GN.
If it is entangled
entropy, it's also entropy.
Maybe it's also
something divided by 4GN.
And maybe it's some
surface divided by 4GN.
And then the special surface
would be the minimal surface.
So in some sense, it's
a very naive guess.
And you could say it's
a very simple guess.
But as I said, it's also
a very difficult guess,
because essentially,
other than that, you don't
have other starting points.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So [INAUDIBLE].
So we have A in the CFT.
Where do we know exactly
where to place A in the AdS?
Because it's not--
HONG LIU: This is
a good question.
This is what I'm
going to say next.
Yeah, but let me
just emphasize that.
So when we talk
about A, we're always
talking about the
constant time slice,
because you have to
specify some time.
And actually, when we
consider the ground state
or typical state does
not depend on time.
And it actually does not
matter which slice we choose.
You just choose a time slice.
And then you specify
region A, because to talk
about degrees of
freedom, you only
talk about it in
the spatial section.
So if you have a ground state
or have any state which does not
depend on time, then
the gravity side
also does not depend on time.
It's a time-dependent geometry.
So time slicing in the
field series naturally
extends in the gravity side.
So in the gravity
side, this surface
would be in the constant
time slicing, which
would go to the gravity side.
AUDIENCE: Professor,
one more thing.
With the CFT and
AdS-- I know we like
to think one existing on
the boundary of the other.
But how does-- that's sort
of an abstraction, right?
HONG LIU: No, that you
should really consider
as a real thing-- real stuff.
Yeah, if you just think
of that as an abstraction,
then you miss a
lot of intuition,
because you use that
as a genuine boundary,
will give you a
lot of intuition.
And many things
become very natural.
Many things become very natural.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So comparing
to the other formula that
also has an area
of the boundary,
all this tells us
is just it helps
us count the number of
degrees of freedom in the CFT.
So it all it tells
us is basically
the epsilon in the denominator?
HONG LIU: No, no, they have a
complete different dimension.
No, this one higher dimension.
AUDIENCE: So that's
another strange--
HONG LIU: No, this is
not strange at all,
because they're not
supposed to be the same.
No, this is the
way it should be.
So this is d minus
1 dimensional.
And that is the d
minus 2 dimensional.
It's just completely different.
AUDIENCE: Well, right,
but they are not-- there
is something the
same about them.
HONG LIU: No, there is
something to same about them.
But these two have
completely different physics.
So this has a close analog
with black hole physics.
Don't think they're
motivated by that formula.
I think they're motivated
by the black hole formula.
And people also try to connect
that formula to the black hole
formula.
That's another story.
Anyway, it doesn't matter.
OK, good.
So this is a guess.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So is this result for
the ground state on the CFT?
HONG LIU: No, this is valid.
Yeah, for the
time-independent state.
The eigenstate is not
invoked with time.
AUDIENCE: The thing
I don't understand
is on the site of the
CFT, there is this state
that you did as an
input to calculate
the entanglement entropy.
And what's the corresponding
thing on the AdS side?
HONG LIU: The AdS side is
the corresponding geometry.
So it's as said before, each
state on the field theory
should correspond
to some geometry
with normalizable modes.
Yeah, so it's the
corresponding geometry.
And the ground state, then
this will be just pure ideas.
And if you look at the
final temperature state,
then this will be
the black hole.
And then if you are able to
construct some other geometry
corresponding to some other
state, you can use that.
AUDIENCE: How about this entropy
on independent on which state
we choose for CFT?
HONG LIU: No, of
course it depends.
No this formula does not.
But the geometry does.
The geometry does.
This is a minimal surface in
whatever [INAUDIBLE] geometry.
AUDIENCE: Does the region--
after we choose the region,
we can choose any state--
HONG LIU: Yes, yes.
AUDIENCE: And as
a minimal surface,
is it independent on
which state we choose?
HONG LIU: Of course, it
would depend on which state
you choose, because
each state corresponds
to a different geometry.
And the minimal surface
depends on your geometry.
So each state-- so
remember previously,
the state on the
CFT side is mapped
to the geometry with
normalizable boundary
conditions with
normalizable modes.
Yeah, anyway, just let
me say just geometry.
So a state with the geometry.
If you have a different state,
you have a different geometry.
But by definition,
all this geometry
would be asymptotic AdS.
So in a boundary, they
should all be asymptotic AdS.
And so that what means to
have [INAUDIBLE] mode excited.
OK?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So this
entropy formula
takes into account the entropy
of gravitational excitations
in AdS, if you can
put it that way.
But black hole entropy--
HONG LIU: No, let's try
not to jump too fast.
And I think you are trying
to extrapolate too fast.
This formula is
supposed to calculate
the entangled entropy
in the field series
side in the [INAUDIBLE]
limit and the notch
lambda toward coupling limit.
And we can talk about the
gravitational interpretation
later.
But this formula is about
the field series entanglement
entropy.
OK?
Good.
Any other questions?
OK, good.
So there are many support of it.
So this is a rule of the game.
You make a guess.
Then you do a check.
If the check worked, then
that gives you confidence,
and then you do another check.
And here you find it will fail.
And if you do a sufficient
number of checks,
then people believed you.
Then people will believe you.
And everybody
started checking it.
And then sooner or
later we will see
whether this fails or works.
Anyway, so this is nice because
this is simple to compute,
because finding a minimal
surface on the gravity side
is in some sense, it's a
straightforward a mathematical
problem conceptually,
even though technically it
may not be simple.
But it's straightforward
conceptually.
Anyway, so you can use these
to calculate many quantities.
Let me just say in
support of this--
let me just say it in
words just to save time.
So the first thing
you should check
is that this satisfies the
subadditive condition which
we wrote down earlier,
because that's
a very non-trivial condition.
It should be satisfied
by the entropy.
So first, you should check that,
because if you violate that,
than this proposal is gone.
And then there are
other things that you
can try to use to reproduce
all the known behavior we know
about entangled
entropy, for example,
this behavior and this
behavior-- this area along.
And then we actually
build up confidence
by checking all
those known results.
And then you can try
to derive [INAUDIBLE]
and to see whether [INAUDIBLE]
makes physical sense.
So essentially,
that's how it works.
And this is nice also
at the tactical level,
because entangled entropy is
something very hard to compute.
I don't know.
You guys may not have experience
of calculating entangled
entropy.
But ask Frank Wilczek.
He was one of the
first few people
to do it in some
free field theory.
Even for free field
theory, people could mostly
do it in 1 plus 1 dimension.
Going beyond 1 plus 1 dimension
free scalar field theory in 2
plus 1 dimension
3 plus 1 dimension
for some simple region
like a circle or sphere
you have to do a
numerical calculation.
You have to discretize
the field theory
to do very massive
numerical calculation.
It's not easy to compute.
But this guy is actually easy
to compute in comparison.
So this guy at the
technical level
provides a huge convenience
to calculate many things.
Yeah, so this is a side remark.
So now let's just do
some calculations.
So first, let me show
that this actually
satisfies strong subaddivity.
So remember, the formula
we had before is S(AC),
unfortunately I erased it.
OK, so this is one
of the inequalities.
So we are just drawing
it 1 plus 1 dimension
because it's easy to draw.
But a similar thing can
be easily generalized
in a higher dimension.
So let's look at just the
line in 1 plus 1 dimension.
So this can call
this region A. This
is region C. This is region B.
You can also make them separate.
It doesn't matter.
It's easy to work out.
So I'm just giving
you one cases.
So suppose a minimal service
for the AC reading is like this.
And the minimal
surface the BC reading
would be like this-- so
minimal surface like that.
So let me call this curve gamma
AC and this curve gamma BC.
OK, I could not find
the colored chalk today.
So I did not have
the colored chalk.
Let me see whether
this chalk works.
Is this the colored chalk?
Yes.
So now, let me define
two other surfaces.
Let me call this one gamma
1 and this one gamma 2.
In principle, I should use
two different chalks for that.
You think it looks
like something?
OK, anyway, so we have
gamma AC plus gamma
BC equals to gamma
1 plus gamma 2
because-- gamma AC-- this
is length-- gamma BC is
equal to gamma 1 plus gamma 2.
And then just from
the definition
of the minimal
surface, then the gamma
1 must be greater than gamma
C in terms of the length
because the minimal
surface associated with C
must be the minimal area.
It must be smaller than gamma 1.
Under the area of gamma 2 must
be greater than gamma ABC,
because the gamma 2 is
the boundary is the ABC.
And the gamma 2 must be
greater than gamma BC
because this is supposed
to be the minimal surface.
So now we conclude that
gamma AC plus gamma
BC is greater than
gamma ABC plus gamma C.
And then this translates
into that formula.
OK?
Very simple, and elegant proof--
very simple and elegant proof.
And now you can prove
another inequality.
You can prove
another inequality,
which is S(AC) plus S(BC)
greater than S(A) and S(B).
So now, I will define
another surface.
OK?
So now, let me just
redraw it-- A, C, B.
So I have AC like this.
I have BC like this.
And now, let me call this one
gamma 1 tilde-- this one gamma
2 tilde.
This is annoying.
OK.
And again, gamma AB plus
gamma AC plus gamma BC
equals to gamma 1 tilde
plus gamma 2 tilde.
So the gamma 1 tilde
ends in A. Gamma
2 tilde ends in B.
That means gamma
1 tilde must be greater than
gamma A and gamma 2 tilde
must be greater
than gamma B. OK?
So now you show that
gamma AC plus gamma
BC is greater than gamma A plus
gamma B. So this is very easy.
So this is a very
simple and elegant.
So if you want to really
to be impressed by this,
I urge you to look at the
proof of the strong subaddivity
itself in say in some textbook
or in the original papers.
It's actually
highly non-trivial.
You need some double,
double concave functions.
It's quite a height involved.
OK, so this is a
great confidence boost
that satisfies the strong
subadditivity condition.
So now, let's look
at the last one.
Let's try to reproduce
this formula.
Let's try to do a
simple calculation
to reproduce this formula.
So this formula is supposed
to be true for any CFT.
This should be also applied
for the holographic CFT
and to check whether
this formula works.
The reason you would like to
choose an example which is new.
But this example
is the simplest.
So that's the reason
I choose this example,
even though it's just
reproduced all the results.
So let's now look at the
entangled entropy of 1
plus 1 dimensional CFT.
So here, now you
have a CFT 1 plus 1
should be dual to the AdS3.
You will do some theory in AdS3.
So the S squared-- so let's
only look at the vacuum
then we just work with AdS3.
So let me write down
the AdS3 metric.
So dx is the
boundary directions.
So as I said, each
CFT is characterized
by a central charge.
And you can obtain
a central charge
from various different ways.
And again, from the
holographic, you
can try to express
the single charge
in terms of gravity quantities.
And there is many ways to derive
it that we will not go through
with that calculation.
So let me just write
down the results.
So far the holographic
CFTs, the single charge
is related to the
gravity quantity
by 3R divided by 2 G Newton.
So this is a result
which I just caught.
I will not derive it for you.
But you can derive it
in many different ways.
So for CFT, to do
a gravity idea 3,
its central charge
is given by 3R,
which is the AdS radius divided
by 2 times the Newton constant.
And the Newton constant
in three dimensions
has mass dimension 1.
So this is a
dimensionless number--
a dimensionless number.
So now let's calculate
the entanglement entropy
using that formula.
So this now reduced
your calculation
very similar to our
Wilson loop calculation.
So let's call this
L divided by 2.
So lets call this X direction.
So this is a V direction.
So this is L divided by 2.
This is minus L divided by 2.
This region is A.
Then we need to find
a curve, because this now 1 plus
1 dimensions-- one dimensions.
So we need to find the curve
which end on this segment of A.
OK?
So is this clear?
So this is the x direction.
And so this is 0, x equals to 0.
Yes?
OK.
So what we need to find is find
the minimal surface connecting
these two points-- a minimal
curve-- a minimal length
curve connecting
these two points.
So it's as we said
before, we should
look at the constant time slice
because this is a vacuum which
is time independent.
Let's look at the
constant time slice.
The constant time
slice, the metric
becomes-- so in this
space, the metric becomes r
square divided by z square
because the time does not
change.
So now if I treat the x as a
function of z, and then these
will become.
So this curve lets
me parametrize
x as a function of z.
Then this just becomes r
square divided by z square 1
plus x prime square dz square.
And so this is dl square.
So the length of
the curve square
would be just
parametrized by this guy.
OK?
And we have to satisfy
the boundary condition--
by symmetry, we only need to
consider the right stuff OK,
because it's symmetric.
So we impose the boundary
condition at the x
z equal to 0.
It's L divided by 2.
We can see the right half.
So now you can just write down
the entanglement entropy now.
So S(A) will be 1 over 4GN.
So I integrate
half of the curve.
Let me just call
here z is equal to 0.
Let me call this point z0.
So I just integrate
from 0 to z0.
Z0 we will find out when you
find out this minimal length
curve.
So this one will be r/z dz.
Then just taking the
square root of this guy--
the square of 1
over x prime square.
So this is the length
and the times 2,
because we only can see
that this is half of it.
And now you extremize it.
Then you find the
minimal length curve.
And then you plug
the solution here.
Then you find the action.
Actually we don't
need to extremize it,
because this is a
well-known problem.
And this is called
the Poincare disk.
So this is a prototype of a
two-dimensional hyperbolic
space.
And the minimal length curve
inside your hyperbolic space
is maybe a 16th century problem.
Yeah, I don't know.
Actually, maybe 17th century.
Anyway, so the answer
is actually very long.
But you can also easily
work out yourself.
So the result is actually
this is just exactly a circle.
OK?
Exactly a half circle.
So that's actually
a half circle.
That means that x equals 2.
The half circle with a
radius L divided by 2.
So this has just
become L squared
divided by 4 minus d square.
In particular, z0 corresponding
to the point which
x equal to 0 just L divided 2.
So now you just
plug this into here.
You just plug this here.
Let me just write it a
little bit fast, because we
are a little bit out of time.
So you plug this in.
Then you can scale the z out.
You can scale z to be scaled
L divided by 2 factors out.
And let me just scale it.
You can rewrite the
integral as follows.
So after the scaling
it's say 2z scale
with L divided by 2z
to do the scaling.
Then you find this
expression becomes 2r/4GN.
And the upper limit becomes 1.
And the lower limit you see.
When you plug this in,
actually the lower limit
is divergent because
there's 1 over z here.
As always, we need
to put the cutoff.
And also, this divergence
is expected because of below
that here it depends
on short distance
cutoff it would be divergent.
So we need to for the
short-distance cutoff here.
So let me put it here epsilon.
And this will be 2
epsilon divided by L
when I do this scaling.
And then you have
dz/z 1 minus d square.
So the integral reduces
to something like this.
And now you can evaluate
this integral trivially.
Then you find the epsilon
goes to the limit.
Then you find the one term
survives 2r divided by 4GN log
L divided by epsilon.
So now let's try
to rewrite in terms
of this C-- we
rewrite in terms of C.
So this is 1/3 3r divided by
2GN log L divided by epsilon.
And so this is precisely
that formula C divided by 3
log L of epsilon.
And with that, you just count
from the minimal surface
in the hyperbolic
space is a circle.
And it takes a lot of effort
to calculate this thing,
even to do a free field
series calculation.
But in gravity you
can do it very easily.
So now let me just
quickly mention
what happens if you do
at a finite temperature.
So you can also do this
So since we're out of time,
we'll be doing it a little bit
fast.
So first doing it at a
finite temperature is easier.
Let me just say finite T.
And then I will connect
to the black hole entropy.
I will show that
this formula actually
reduces to the black hole
entropy in some limits.
So for these problems,
actually, it's
easier to consider
CFT on the circle.
OK.
So when the CFT
is on the circle,
the boundary will be
a circle because this
is 1 plus 1 dimension.
So remember, in
the global ideas,
it's like sitting
there in the boundary.
And in the 1 plus 1 dimensional
case and the boundary
is just really a circle.
And this is the bark
And a finite temperature,
you put the black hole there.
Let me just put the
black hole here.
OK?
Just put the black hole there.
So now you can ask the
following question.
So now let's consider
some reaching A. So
let's consider A is very small.
Yo can work out the
minimal surface.
So it acts the same as
our Wilson loop story.
So you find a minimal surface.
But if A is sufficiently
small, then the geometry around
here is still AdS.
And then you just
get a minimal surface
around here-- so a
small deformation
from the vacuum behavior.
So we'll make A
larger and larger.
So this z0 depends on L. If
we make L larger and larger,
this is z0 will be
deeper in the bark.
So if you make A larger, so
this will go more to the bark
and then will be
deformed, and then we'll
see the black hole geometry.
But now to answer
the question how
about if I make A to be
larger-- this region to be
A to be larger than the half
of the size of the circle.
So the minimal surface
should be able to be
to be smoothly
deformed back into A.
So now you have to do
something like this.
It turns out the minimal surface
want to go around the horizon
and then doing
something like this.
AUDIENCE: Why don't you do
it the other way around?
HONG LIU: No, it's
because the other won't.
It's because A is like this.
And if you do
something like this,
then it can be
deformed back into A.
It's mostly without
crossing the black hole.
AUDIENCE: Yes, or it could be
like a phase jump or something
at some point when one
surface becomes longer than
[INAUDIBLE].
HONG LIU: No, in this
situation, it's not that thing.
It's something like this.
Now, if you make A even
longer, eventually,
let's take the A even longer.
And that would be
something like this.
Yeah, because you always
want to hug near the horizon.
And eventually, we'll
make A to be tiny,
then it will become
something like this.
You have something
close on the horizon.
Then you have
something like this.
It's roughly
Yeah, is it clear to you?
It doesn't matter.
[LAUGHTER]
So now let's consider--
anyway, yeah,
let me just draw this again.
It actually does matter.
Sorry.
So let's take A
to be very small.
Let's take A to be a very big.
This part will be very small.
So we are finally we
will go like this.
Anyway, something like this
when you hug the black hole.
And eventually, when
these two points shrink,
so take A with the total region.
Take A to be the total space.
What do you get?
Then what you see that the
minimal surface essentially
is just essentially a surface
hugger on the horizon.
And this is a precise
black hole formula,
because then this is a
imprecise a black hole formula.
And this is a situation you
expect it to be black hole
formula, because if you take
the A to be the host space,
then rho A is just equal to
the rho of the whole system.
And the S(A) by definition
is just equal to the S
of the whole system.
And this is just a thermal
density, a thermal entropy.
And this is given by
the black hole formula.
It's given by the
black hole formula.
And this is given
by [INAUDIBLE].
So you find in these
special cases, actually,
you recover the
black hole formula.
So I have some small things.
We can talk a little bit more.
But I think we'll skip it.
You can also show that actually
for general dimensions,
you always recover the area
more without the details
of the geometry, because no
matter what kind of dimension
you look at, the
typical state which will
be normalizable to geometry.
When you approach the AdS--
when you approach the boundary,
it's always like AdS.
And then you find in
a higher dimension,
it's always like this.
It says, when this
minimal surface
is close to the boundary,
it becomes perpendicular
to the boundary.
Here is a circle,
then of course,
it's perpendicular
to the boundary.
But you see this
feature is actually
generalized to higher
dimensions-- to any dimensions.
So what you see is that
in the general dimension,
a minimal surface will be
just near the boundary will
be just perpendicular to
going down from everywhere.
And then from
there, you can show
that you always have the
area law from this behavior.
You always have the area law.
So this can give you an
exercise for yourself.
Yeah, so let me just
finish by saying
a couple of philosophical
remarks, and then we'll finish.
So this RT formula
is really remarkable,
because it's actually,
as I said, technically
provides a very simple way to
calculate entangled entropy.
But actually, conceptually,
it's even more profound
because it tells you that
the space time is related
to the entanglement, because
it simulates something which
is very subtle from the field
theory side, because this S(A),
as we said, you have to do
some complicated procedure
to trace out degrees of
freedom-- take the log.
And that turns out to be
related to the geometry
in a very simple way.
So essentially, you see that
entanglement-- it's just
captured by the space time.
And in particular,
it's something
you can say the
geometry is essentially
equal to the
quantum information.
So this is a very exciting
also from the gravity
perspective, because if they
ask you if you really understand
this duality, then you can
actually using the quantum
information of the field theory
to understand the subtle things
about the geometry.
It just tells you the
geometry is actually
equal to the
quantum information.
So for many years, actually not
that many years, so previously,
we have people doing
quantum information.
And we have people doing
this matter, which is
the quantum many-body system.
And this matter, or QCD, so this
is kind of quantum many-body.
And then we have people doing
black hole, string theory,
and the gravity.
So they are all very
different fields.
But now, they're all connected
by this holographic duality.
Somehow essentially,
they connect all of them.
So now, we essentially
just see a unified picture,
a unified paradigm, to
understand all quantum systems,
including quantum systems
without gravity, with gravity.
So I will stop here.
[APPLAUSE]